speaking of anti-semitism we have had
another attack that fits the bill
a former black Israelite I will explain
what that means in a second shot up a
kosher market in Jersey City in New
Jersey
yesterday six people were shot dead
total including two shooters five of
them in the kosher grocery store called
JC kosher supermarket one of the
perpetrators previously wrote many
anti-semitic things on social media
according to law enforcement and is
reportedly a former black Israelite the
black Israelite movement we will get to
that in a moment the the perpetrator had
been previously arrested in 2004 2007 on
weapons charges and 2009 for criminal
mischief so what is this black Israelite
thing now black Israelites are a fixture
often when you come out of the subway in
New York City they will proselytize
there I have been approached by black
Israelites when I lived in New York City
black Israelites are sometimes called
black Hebrews and generally speaking I
want to do as good a job of accurately
but not over representing what they
believe black Israelites claim to be the
real Jews now they are not Ethiopian
Jews they're Ethiopian Jews or something
else and if you don't know about that
it's not today's subject but black
Israelites are something else they claim
to be the actual and true descendants of
the biblical children of Israel the
individuals described in the Bible they
say that other Jews what are
colloquially known as white Jews are
imposters they're not really Jewish
they're not really the descendants of
the people in the Bible they are
considered a black nationalist group the
likes of the Nation of Islam of course
with very different fundamental beliefs
as you can probably imagine here and
what we are realizing is that
anti-semitism is a very real and growing
21st century problem and you might say
well but David hold on how can people
who say that they are the real Jews be
anti-semitic you can claim to be
anything you want if your fundamental
belief is that white Jews are devilish
imposters who deserve death or slavery
that's anti-semitic and this is a
growing problem unfortunately in the US
and around the world I recently
mentioned this and there there are so
many different reports about it some of
which I'll tell you about right now the
European Union agency for Fundamental
Rights has a report out which finds
pervasive anti-semitism in Europe
visibly so in some places where public
harassment is actually commonplace in
France the cncd H has a big report about
the growth of anti-semitism in France a
Germany saw a 20 percent rise in
anti-semitic crime in 2018 most of it
comes unsurprisingly from far-right
groups the community Security Trust has
a report out which found the highest
number of anti-semitic incidents ever in
the United Kingdom in 2018 the 2019 AJC
survey of anti-semitism in America finds
that American Jews are feeling less safe
than they felt in a very long time and
then the anti-defamation league in 2018
recorded the third highest number of
anti-semitic incidents in American
history over the four decades that they
have tracked this that's how far back
that goes and what does Donald Trump do
well as I told you earlier he says let's
pass an executive order to label Judaism
a nationality which is not only
completely incorrect on facts it is also
absolutely counterproductive and only
furthers this anti-semitic trope of
Jewish dual loyalty by suggesting that
an American Jew born in the US who maybe
has never even been to Israel as most
Jews I believe have not might have
something in their nationality that is
anything other than simply being an
American person we already talked about
that this incident at the kosher market
in Jersey City is absolutely a horrible
one and for
some reason there were people contacting
me saying I wouldn't cover this incident
because the perpetrator was black and
not white I have that I don't know what
other shows are doing cuz I don't watch
other shows but shying away from stories
on this program but newsworthy stories
based on the identity of the
perpetrators or victims that is not
something that we have done we've been
doing this show for a long time and that
is not something that I do we'll address
that later in the voicemail segment
we'll take a quick break the latest from
tucker carlson coming up and many more
things that I want to discuss with you
today